grab a seat
how are you very well they're all here
to see me they didn't know okay
uh you have a lot of fans here I guess
my first question is an obvious one but
maybe maybe we'll learn something
you're challenging a sitting U.S
president in your party you have to have
good reason to do so tell us what it is
well you know I saw a first of all thank
you for having me Sean thank you
everybody for showing up
I saw I saw a poll yesterday afternoon
that said that in 1985
85 percent of Americans were proud to be
American
85 Americans between 18 and 30 years old
and a poll taken last week of people
that same age of Americans that same age
that only 42 percent are proud to be
American
I um I want my children to grow up as
proud of this country as I was and you
know I grew up at a time when we believe
with with really good reason that this
country was the greatest country in
history and that we are a moral
Authority around the world
uh that we were in and there was plenty
of evidence for that the world wanted
our leadership they knew the difference
between leadership and bullying but
people all over the world looked to on
the United States of America for
leadership
um when my uncle was President he lived
up to that to that role um and there is
now more
statues to him uh more more boulevards
named after him or Avenues more
universities in Africa and Asian Latin
America than any other president
and it offends the uh you know because
he didn't focus on shooting people and
uncending he never sent combat veteran
abroad or combat Soldier abroad to die
he said 16 000 military advisers to
Vietnam and then awarded them all home
one month before he died and they were
allowed to participate in combat
exercises some of them did
and um and instead he's on he's got
volunteers he created the alliance for
Progress he created U.S Aid he wanted to
put America on the side of the poor all
over the world and on the side of
democracy but not at the force of a gun
in this country
you know what I grew up at a time that's
called it was called the Great
Prosperity when we created the middle
class which was the greatest in economic
engine ever created the American Medical
class and it was that it was the
foundation it's not our democracy
a guy asked me a New Yorker
editor who interviewed me a couple of
weeks ago said to me what qualifies you
to be president you've never been in
Congress you've never been a governor
you've never been in the Senate
and for me that's probably the best
qualification
because
I'm not I'm not saying anything bad
about people I think most people who are
in public office are there because they
want to be good citizens they want to be
good public servants
but the system nowadays tends to go up
to you and you know to run for Senator
in this stage Sean it costs 100 million
dollars and that means that you have to
spend most of your time chatting between
Southampton and Palm Beach in Los
Angeles and hang out with billionaires
who are going to give you money
my job over the past 40 years has been
suing government agencies for corruption
and
representing representing people 10 000
families in smelter West Virginia are
poisoned by zinc from uh and lead from a
Dupont uh smelting facility
let's say a thousand families I'm now
representing in Colombiana County
Pennsylvania or Ohio
for the Norfolk Southern spill
um the the ten thousand families I
represented in the DuPont case who were
poisoned by pfas and pfoas and the 40
000 people I represented in Monsanto
and I am and fishermen who I've you know
represented as you know my whole life on
the Hudson and other places
and I end up seeing how people live that
I've seen the disintegration of the
American dream and the American
experience I've seen on not only the
social and economic uh deprivation that
now exists in this country that's like
what I saw in Latin America when I was a
kid and I never dreamed I'd see it in
this country
57 of Americans can't put their hands on
a thousand dollars if they have an
emergency how scary is that 35 of our
our of people in this country do not
make enough money to pay for basic human
needs for for transportation
housing and food so they have to make
choices every day they have to listen to
the baby crying in the in the room next
door and have to wonder where that baby
is thirty dollars sick or forty dollars
or two hundred dollars a sick before
they bring them to a hospital they have
to choose between heat and food between
medicine and food my wife and I had this
discussion my wife grew up very very
poor and until she you know got a Break
by getting the job from Larry David on
Curb Your Enthusiasm she was living in
power she's great on that show it really
is yeah you like that show good job
and she said
she said to me you know the whole time I
was I was living paycheck to paycheck
and she said by the way so was I yeah I
can identify with that and you know that
is not fun it's frightening and she said
you know we were talking about how
depression and mental illness rates and
suicide raids have risen just
dramatically in this country and she
said well being poor makes you depressed
because you're scared all the time and
you think there's something wrong with
you and you know this is not the America
that I let me ask you but I I hear
everything I'm listening very closely to
what you say and you're saying that we
can do better and I agree with you we
have nearly you know over 60 percent of
this country living paycheck to paycheck
the average American owes fifty four
fifty five thousand dollars in debt uh
people are cashing in their pensions to
get Bare Necessities or they're putting
stuff on credit cards at you know 22 and
a half percent interest rate now I would
argue that's part of the Biden economy
and and you know the only difference
where we might well we might separate
here is whether or not you think it
ought to be a government program I think
it's free market economies that Inspire
entrepreneurs and you have the freedom
and the ability to bring goods and
services to Market versus say the
government giving you your bare
necessities I mean yeah of course and
nobody wants that nobody wants to live
on the government doll
um but uh and it is I mean we don't have
free market capitalism in this country
we have corporate crony capitalism
[Applause]
we have a system of of cushy socialism
for the super rich and the this uh
brutal
a kind of brutal Savage merciless
capitalism for the poor and it's all
designed to strip behind the middle
class of this country of all of their
Equity all of their assets and move it
to the upper echelons hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else